prendre deux meurtres ont été commis en
2018 sur le territoire du spvm c'est un
portrait qui n'est pas hors norme on
compare ce chiffre à ceux des dernières
années faut mentionner que plusieurs de
ces homicides sont liées au crime
organisé qui lui s'est complètement
réorganisé et pour brosser le portrait
de la scène policière et du crime
organisé en 2018 daniel renaud damman
journal est spécialisé dans la question
vous connaissez bien ça on le dit donc
32 à montréal c'est plus que en fait
c'est plus qu'en 2010 mais 32 meurtre à
montréal commis en 2018 jusqu'à
maintenant marquer que là n'est pas tout
à fait finie c'est quand même huit de
plus que l'année dernière on a fini avec
c'est une rose donc de 30% par rapport à
l'année dernière mais c'est pas c'est
pas beaucoup quand j'ai commencé ma
carrière la fin des années 80 on parlait
de 70 à 90 meurtres
il y avait eu aussi dans les années 90
la guerre des moteurs s'est pas beaucoup
32 non plus comparativement toronto qui
a fini l'année avec 95 meurtre le mot
très spécifiques et en retour notamment
terroristes
oui oui oui exactement mais quand même
on savoir où l'on est loin on est loin
de toronto par contre j'ai l'impression
que ça pourra pas faire autrement que
d'augmenter un peu au fil des prochaines
années tellement c'était beau ces
dernières années alors on se rappelle
aussi 2018 c'est le ménage au spvm très
gros ménage d'ailleurs qui avait été
entrepris par martin prud'homme alors
est-ce que le ménage a été fait selon
ouais c'est en décembre 2000
17 que martin prud'homme était arrivé
personnellement j'aurais pensé qu'ils
seraient incités peut-être une autre
année de plus par contre et il est parti
et il a laissé la suite avec
l'approbation du gouvernement et de la
ville à sylvain caron mais vous savez
sylvain caron c'est un ancien directeur
général adjoint de la sûreté du québec 2
martin prud'homme dans le fond lui va
continuer l'oeuvre amorcé par martin
prud'homme et j'ai l'impression sans te
tromper que les deux hommes vont
continuer à se parler
je pense que le son de continuité oui
c'est oui c'est une continuité sur une
consolidation de ce qui a été fait et
c'est la préparation éventuellement à un
futur directeur qui cette fois ci sera
probablement issu des rangs internes du
spvm et la relève n'est pas encore prête
aux dires de la direction actuelle mais
je pense que le ménage est fait mais
c'est pas tout à fait finie en rappelez
vous il ya encore des enquêtes de
l'équipe mix de numériser les aviations
spvm et on n'a toujours pas les
résultats de ces enquêtes là il y avait
certaines rumeurs qui voulaient qu'on
ait ces résultats-là cet automne à la
fin de l'automne
mais ça a été assez divers de donc
attendez-vous à ce que le tag février
donc on commence à voir des résultats de
ces enquêtes donc à surveiller vraiment
au début d'année retour des aides
on a tous vu ces images du mariage du
fameux mariage est ce que c'est le
retour des aides
officiellement le retour des 11 j'ai
l'impression que ça fait depuis
2013-2014 qu'on parle du retour des
hells angels
mais je pense que 2008 a été l'année de
confirmation de la présence des hells
angels tout en haut de la pyramide du
crime organisé au québec et c'est venu
un peu se consacrer avec le mariage
auquel on assiste et il doit partir de
là vue finalement le 1er décembre
dernier
martin robert qui s'est marié c'est un
membre influent des hells angels de
montréal qui était pas connue du public
avant et qui maintenant les et je pense
que par ce mariage là les hells angels
envoie un message
ils sont de retour même un message un
peu d'arrogance
ils sont ils seront en 2019 l'ennemi
numéro 1 à abattre du côté des forces
policières même c'est eux qui contrôlent
montréal qui contrôlent québec le québec
et qui mène dans une certaine mesure
domine par rapport au crime organisé
traditionnel italien qui a toujours été
la source du crime organisé étaient
dominantes au québec mais
particulièrement rien c'est justement là
dessus je le ferais deviez nouveaux
visages d'ailleurs en présidant le crime
organisé italien leonardo à résoudre
taux qui prend la relève est en fait
leonardo rizzuto qui est le fils cadet
de vito rizzuto le parent qui est décédé
il ya cinq ans de causes naturelles
c'est un nom qui est évoqué par la
police mais il sera jamais probablement
moins con on assiste un virage
spectaculaire un peu comme les séries
télé les films le parrain ou man called
qui n'était pas celui qui était destiné
à devenir parent finalement le devient
mais ça serait très surprenant et
actuellement c'est important de le
préciser
le crime organisé à montréal et au
québec
tout le monde est mélangé mafia hells
angels gangs de rue
autre groupe les libéraux tout seulement
de l'eau travaillent ensemble et c'est
vraiment il ya une paix relative
actuellement donc il ya des gens qui
contrôlent tout ça c'est les uns aux
autres merci beaucoup d'ailleurs merci
bonne année bonne on avoue